[Music]  the president gave a graduation speech  yesterday at a high school I have to say  he's such a great speaker President  Obama I did not find this speech that  inspiring for students take a look  congratulations on your graduation and  thank you for allowing me the honor of  playing a small part in this special day  so today as you begin the next stage in  your journey wherever you're going  whatever you're doing it's safe to say  you will encounter greed and selfishness  and ignorance and cruelty and sometimes  just bad luck I guarantee you you will  face setbacks and you will face  disappointments life involves struggles  looking after others is only for suckers  congratulations  [Applause]  it's a real downer he's not wrong